we've been talking here a lot about the
war overseas but we are also as you know
fighting a war right here at home for
the streets of our cities and here are
the latest examples of the wicked battle
being waged a suspected serial killer
has been arrested in connection with the
heinous set of shootings that targeted
vulnerable homeless people in new york
city and washington dc that killing
spree leaving two dead injuring three
others and another man has been charged
with a hate crime look at this animal
for the horrific beating of an asian
woman the racist punk stomping punching
the 67 year old woman in the head more
than 125 times she suffered multiple
contusions lacerations bleeding on the
brain
another asian woman victimized in stable
condition after that assault it's a it's
a miracle first comment on that
i hate it i hate it you know what this
is what this is what we voted for in new
york i know we're talking about new york
now you have a cultural institution the
museum of modern art you're a young
woman working behind the desk and some
some guy normal looking guy comes in
he's upset you know with that he's
his permit was revoked or whatever he
jumps the desk to stab you and your
girlfriend the see the people that are
committing the people who are commit
co-worker people are committing these
crimes are committing them over and over
and over again and don't think all you
social justice warriors don't think that
you're saving one guy because he
committed or made one mistake they
commit mistake after mistake they
continue on their crime sprees until
they're stopped and i know this i know
this i know it in my in my in my dna
from having done this for 30 years and
i'm not surprised that this guy one of
the attackers had 22 prior convictions
it's our fault that they're running
around and victimizing us i don't want
to i don't want to take all the time but
unless you change the bail law in new
york state and unless we get rid of
these progressive da's then we've got no
hope that you just better hope that if
you get shot or stabbed that you don't
die because justice ain't coming the
cavalry ain't coming and you're never
going to get any kind of retribution in
ohio yesterday mike dewine the governor
passed a law that allows concealed carry
even without a license or any training
is that a solution
i guess when the if the cavalry ain't
coming that's a solution and you can't
disarm a public if you also have uh
no consistent law enforcement you know
there's another part of this that we've
talked about before it drives me crazy
you know this moma suspect is was
homeless
probably mentally ill all these people
stabbing people homeless mentally ill
the serial killer claims by his dad to
be mentally ill at a certain point you
know despite all the billions that we've
spent on the mentally ill
it all goes into the pockets of the
administrators so maybe we just stop
like what are we supposed to do if we're
supposed to help the mentally ill but we
leave them on the streets and we let
them you know maybe we just treat them
like criminals arrest them and put them
away but that seems even
even worse but we've got no choice so
we keep pointing out these liberal laws
and nothing changes this is just like
talking about the war we talk about how
horrible things are but then we go like
what do we do we've been doing this for
three years we got nothing it's getting
worse
erica was in town sandra over the
weekend and went shopping on madison
avenue
noting some some of the stores still
closed from the riots
but mostly noticing how prevalent
homeless people are on the premier
shopping
boulevard of the premier city in the
country
does anything
suggest dysfunction more eloquently than
that visible
problem where all of these people
whatever their background or all over
the place i hope she watched her back
every time she turned a corner or walked
down a block because it's scary in new
york city right now and that is fact the
crime is running rampant it's not just
here but the one attack in seattle stood
out to me and broke my heart this long
time health care worker
she was on her way up at a rail station
she was going up the stairs when a
career criminal in an unprovoked attack
grabbed her 62 years old through that
nurse down the stairs yes he alexander j
40 years old
cement steps she suffered a broken
clavicle three broken ribs she was
rushed to the hospital the very hospital
where she has worked for 25 years
helping other people that gives me
chills that is awful and that is just
one example of the many unprovoked
attacks that are happening in these
cities all over the country mentally ill
or not
a crime is a crime
that's why i think the judge's point
about bill reform is the one that
resonates because when you commit a
crime you should be charged to the
fullest extent of the law
held if you are a threat to society
pre-trial and then uh given the full
sentence if you're convicted we can't do
anything if the liberals won't help us
do anything right although
you can't live in a society if half the
society doesn't want to live in a
civilization exactly we can crow about
this all day we've been showing this for
two and a half years this crime wave and
everybody knows what needs to be done
but no one does it yep so we're just
sitting here complaining because liberal
politicians don't care they just don't
care
line look at this guy look at this
look at this look at this yeah can you
believe they're going to go to work
in albany and not do a damn thing about
it you don't see that you will not see
that on other networks this stuff
doesn't exist oh
yeah i'm talking about no consequences
to crying you know what they did today
in congress they
memorialized daylight savings time yes
that's what they did well that was they
made daily life savings she's permanent
i was worried about all over the streets
and that's what their business convicted
uh convicted hate crime hoaxer jessie
smollette already scheming to get out of
prison